l'invité de paris direct
[Musique]
bonjour elisabeth claverie de saint
martin merci de venir jusqu'à nous vous
êtes président général du cirad qui est
le centre de coopération internationale
en recherche agronomique pour le
développement est avec vous ce matin
nous allons nous arrêter sur les
possibles risques alimentaires au niveau
mondial en lien avec la guerre nuque
raide mais pas uniquement question
simple pour commencer à raison de ce
conflit est ce qu'il y à des risques de
famine dans le monde
malheureusement la famine est déjà
présente dans le monde puisqu'on a à peu
près 700 à 800 millions de personnes qui
en souffrent et c'est essentiellement dû
au conflit mais pas simplement au
conflit en ukraine essentiellement au
conflit sur les zones où sévit la famine
est donc en ce moment beaucoup la corne
de l'afrique notamment avec toute la la
partie ethiopie somalie et puis aussi au
changement climatique qui devient de
plus en plus une cause de famine ça ce
sont les autres deux filles défilent
mais pour revenir à cette situation de
l'ukraine on peut rappeler que la russie
et l'ukraine représente 30 % des
échanges mondiaux de blé et la moitié de
ses 30 % va vers l'afrique des analystes
estiment que le blé est devenu une arme
au même titre que les bombes est ce que
vous partagez ce point de vue alors
peut-être si vous me permettez deux
points le premier point c'est de dire
que l'augmentation des denrées
alimentaires et notamment du blé elle ne
date pas de ces crises ont nos
chercheurs ont remarqué que depuis un an
depuis 2000 la fin de la période que
vides fin 2020 les prix augmentaient de
80% donc en fait il ya déjà eu un prix
il ya déjà une augmentation des denrées
alimentaires due à l'augmentation du
pétrole des énergies fossiles d'une part
et d'autre part due à la reprise post
qu'ovide essentiellement en asie donc on
est déjà dans un contexte de surchauffe
où il ya une augmentation des denrées
alimentaires
le deuxième point c'est qu'en fait
s'agissant de l'afrique il ne faut pas
parler du continent il faut différencier
parce que les situations sont très
différentes au moins sur trois critères
le premier critère
vous venez dire la consommation de blé
au fond qui consomment et est-ce que
c'est fondamental pour l'apport
calorique et là on retrouve beaucoup de
pays d'afrique du nord plus par exemple
le soudan le yémen certains pays
d'afrique mais le blé s'agissant de
l'afrique subsaharienne
n'est pas forcément le premier aliment
donc ça c'est le premier facteur je
dirais qui permet de dire de quantifier
le risque de famille le deuxième c'est
savoir si les pays ont la possibilité de
compenser cette hausse du prix et
aujourd'hui cette possibilité de
compenser elle est principalement dû au
fait qu'ils peuvent ou non tirées des
revenus additionnels de la hausse des
prix des autres matières premières et
pour parler de l'afrique subsaharienne
de l'ouest de l'afrique centrale on sait
qu'il y a des pistes alternatives aux
oeufs au blé il ya par exemple la banane
plantain et millions de tonnes par an
sur le continent selon ce que dit votre
centre le cirad on pense aussi au manioc
ou au sorgho a transformé en farine est
ce que cette piste sont viables à
l'échelle macro nous le pensons déjà il
faut rappeler que l'afrique est elle
s'auto nourris à 80% donc il faut
enlever les images d'une afrique qui
serait très dépendantes l'agriculture
africaine elle est dynamique elle
n'arrive pas tout à fait à suivre la
croissance démographique mais elle est
très dynamique deuxièmement elle est
quand même très diversifié et elle a la
chance s'agissant d'afrique
subsaharienne ne pas être très
dépendante des cours des cours
internationaux justement parce que s'il
ya cette diversification les racines et
tubercules dont on a parlé la banane
plantain on y croit la banane plantain
c'est à la fois très nourrissant c'est
un c'est un produit traditionnel
qui fonctionne très bien qui nécessitent
assez peu de pesticides d'engrais et
puis elle dépend beaucoup du riz qui
aujourd'hui n'a pas flambé donc cette
afrique subsaharienne elle peut se
nourrir elle sait se nourrir et elle a
une diversité de produits et nous
militons beaucoup au cirad pour ce que
l'on appelle l' intensification agro
écologique c'est-à-dire une mentation
des rendements des productions
africaines sans pour autant mettre
beaucoup plus d'engrais et de pesticides
et les à m lavery de saint martin la
voir revenir la zone et ce sur le manger
demain l'alimentation de mai mais on
revient encore sur le diagnostic que
nous sommes en train de faire l'afrique
de l'ouest l'afrique centrale le
moyen-orient le maghreb on l'a vu qu'en
est il d'un pays comme le yémen qui est
un poids en ce moment à ce que les
nations unies appelle la plus grave
catastrophe humanitaire en cours en
lui-même est effectivement un pays dans
une situation dramatique d'abord parce
que c'est un pays en guerre et en guerre
depuis longtemps deuxièmement parce que
c'est un pays pour lequel les l'apport
calorique dépend pour la moitié du blé
humble et qu'il importe essentiellement
et non seulement il n'a plus les moyens
d'acheter ce blé il n'a pas le moyen de
l'aide de le distribuer parce que le
pays est en guerre et les porcs sont eux
mêmes aussi en guerre donc on est
vraiment sur une situation très
classique de conflits et les conflits
amène la famine les systèmes
alimentaires mondiaux aujourd'hui 2
milliards de producteurs 7 milliards et
quelques de consommateurs 700 millions
de personnes vous l'avez rappelé tout à
l'heure menacées de famine comment
nourrir ce beau monde tout au moins à
moyen terme alors c'était c'était le
thème que nous avions choisi pour le
ciss le sommet pour le salon
international d'agriculture cette année
justement pourront dialoguer avec le
grand public et est notre idée c'est
qu'il faut vraiment changer radicalement
les systèmes alimentaires et il faut les
changer du côté de la production
notamment en ayant des productions qui
sont moins
dévastatrice et pour la biodiversité et
pour le changement climatique il faut
rappeler que les systèmes alimentaires
au sens large la production le transport
la transformation c'est un tiers des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre c'est
pas négligeable donc un système de
production qui est plus conforme à la
durabilité à ce que nous voulons qui est
meilleur pour la santé mais aussi un
système de consommation qui va falloir
changer avec plus de fruits et de
légumes avec moins de productions
animales une grande diversité des
céréales et ça tombe bien
c'est ça aussi qui permettra de changer
le système de production dans un sens
vertueux votre centre le cirad se veut
un instrument de politique publique
orientés vers des solutions innovantes
cette structure gouvernementale
ces solutions innovantes pour ceux qui
ne sont pas au fait de la chose à quoi
est-ce qu'elles peuvent concrètement
ressemblait alors nous intervenons
essentiellement dans des zones
tropicales puisque l'agriculture
tropicale n'est pas la même que
l'agriculture des zones tempérées donc
ça nous amène à à intervenir en afrique
mais aussi sur les territoires ultra
marins français qui ont des
particularités en termes d'agriculture
il ya beaucoup d'innovation notamment
pour réduire les intrants pour réduire
notamment les pesticides qui sont aussi
dangereux pour la santé et nous mettons
au point des solutions les solutions ça
peut être par exemple de lutter contre
certaines maladies
avec des produits innovants de lutter
contre certains agresseurs de la nature
qui dévorent les cultures avec d'autres
agresseurs de mettre en place des
systèmes de rotation de cultures de
mettre en place ce qu'on appelle en
termes un peu politique l'agroécologie
est donc d'arriver par ses innovations
qui prennent en compte le savoir qu'ils
existent sur le terrain le savoir des
agriculteurs qui ont déjà beaucoup de
connaissances sur ce qu'on peut faire
des études scientifiques
de la recherche et la mise au point de
nouveaux protocoles l'agro-industrie
d'entourer à quelle place occupe-t-elle
dans vos dans votre démarche alors
l'agro-industrie elle existe il ne faut
surtout pas l'ignorer puisque c'est elle
qui au niveau mondial produit quand même
beaucoup même si la petite agriculture
familiale ce qu'on appelle l'agriculture
traditionnelle ça reste le principal
facteur de production dans le monde mais
il n'empêche l'agro industrie progresse
et elle n'est pas toujours à un facteur
négatif donc nous ce que nous cherchons
c'est à travailler avec elle quand elle
a des engagements pour justement aller
vers cette transformation des systèmes
productifs nourrir les populations de
demain ça veut dire faire appel encore
plus peut-être à la science
en mai 2021 elizabeth smart haine que la
vraie vous avez lancé une initiative
gouvernementale visant à prévenir les
pandémies plus spécifiquement les
zoonoses où en est cette initiative
alors cette initiative s'appelle
président ce n'est pas que le cirad 1
elle est portée aussi par l'inra et
l'ird et qui sont deux autres instituts
de recherche français et surtout elle
est portée par une quantité importante
plus d'une centaine de centres de
recherche mondiaux
elle a été lancée sous le patronage du
président de la république et elle
cherche effectivement au lieu de penser
la santé en termes de silos à réfléchir
à la prévention des risques en intégrant
la santé humaine la santé animale est ce
qu'on appelle la santé des écosystèmes
c'est un peu compliqué mais grosso modo
c'est de dire que les virus
n'apparaissent pas comme ça il y à des
dérèglements et dans ses interactions on
doit les pensées et on doit mettre en
place des systèmes de surveillance qui
nous permettrait en cas d'un autre
épisode d'un autre virus que le
coronavirus d'agir à temps ou qu'on soit
clair ça sera votre dernier mot demain
tout le monde mangera correctement à sa
fin
techniquement tout le monde peut manger
à sa faim ont produit largement assez
pour que tout le monde mange à sa faim
c'est donc un problème d'acheminement de
répartition de revenu et aussi de
coopération internationale et je crois
qu'aujourd'hui c'est ce dont on a le
plus besoin merci beaucoup sinon de
saint-martin d'être venu jusqu'à non pdg
du cirad le centre de coopération
internationale en recherche agronomique
pour le développement c'était l'invité
de paris direct merci reste avec nous
l'information internationale continue
sur nos chaînes
[Musique]